could you see yourself dating a
non-celebrity yeah
absolutely i thought about this and then
i thought
you can do it all you can do whatever
you want that's kim kardashian opening
up about her love life
following her split with kanye west it's
a different experience for sure
on thursday andy cohen hosted the
keeping up with the kardashians reunion
capping off 20 seasons of the family's
reality show
phenomenon between the six of you you've
had nine
spin-offs two of you are billionaires
you've had headline making relationships
leading to
three marriages and three and a half
divorces during part one of the tv
special the family opened up about their
relationships
at what point in your friendship did you
say i'm in love with this guy i would
say
six months after my divorce with chris
humphries
but they also looked to the future and
kim reacted to whether she would be
open to dating someone who's maybe not a
household name
could you see yourself dating a
non-celebrity yeah
absolutely just someone that's you know
i think would understand what this life
is about though
but i think what i was looking for and
who i was
you know years ago is completely
different than who i am today and i
value privacy
and i just want something that's like
really real but there have been whispers
of some high-profile romances
and thankfully andy wanted the scoop
just as much as we did
there are rumors that you're dating van
jones
van text me and was like this rumor has
gotten me so many dates
and i'm so grateful so i rumors that
you're dating maluma
no i'm not dating either one not van
jones not maluma
i've i've known him i've seen him a few
times always in miami
such a nice guy and what might kim's
dating profile look like
well she did give us some hints when the
chat turned to her glam-shot-packed
instagram account
and how it might evolve as she focuses
on the next chapter of her career
so you're now transitioning to
become a lawyer will you pull back on
presenting yourself so suggestively or
thought about this and then i thought
you can do it all you can do whatever
you want like when i remember going to
the white house one time and i was like
i just posted a bikini pic i hope you
know they're not looking at my instagram
while i'm you know in here but i will
say that
i don't know there's something so
freeing about feeling like
i'm 40 and i look i'm in the best shape
of my life
but no matter where her love life goes
from here kim says she's committed to a
co-parenting relationship with kanye for
their four
children there's nothing that
i think parents would want more than to
see or even kids want more than to see
their parents together
how was your relationship with him today
we have an amazing co-parenting
relationship
and i i respect him so much and i think
we
i think will have you know that was my
friend first
first and foremost for a long time so i
can't see that going away
you